>>Male Presenter: So it's my great pleasure
to introduce one of the deepest and most prolific
economists.
Joe Stiglitz.
Joe is a superb academic who has extensively
applied his expertise in the political sphere.
As well as in the journals.
Joe is famous for studies of the affects of
asymmetric information.
For which he won the Nobel Prize in 2001.
He's one of the earliest to apply game theoretic
reasoning for studying policy issues.
His work revolutionized the study of credit
markets, insurance, development, and the theory
of the firm, where he is responsible for the
concept of efficiency wages.
You should all like efficiency wages.
That's what gets us paid more than the competition.
He served in the Clinton Administration as
the Chair of the President's Council on Economic
Advisers.
He also served as Chief Economist of the World
Bank where he's noted for criticizing the
World Bank.
[laughter]
He's a co-author of the inter-governmental
panel on climate change.
More recently he's, Joe Stiglitz has been
advising Obama but has also been sharply critical
of the Obama Administration's financial industry
rescue plan.
To give a quote, he said "Whoever designed
the bank rescue plan is either in the pocket
of the banks, or incompetent."
[laughter]
And I hope he will tell us which.
Without further ado, let me introduce one
of the best economists, Joe Stiglitz.
[extended applause]
>>Joe: Well, it's a real pleasure to be here
again.
The subject of course, that I'm talking about
is not so, uh, attractive.
The topic is "The price of inequality.
How today's divided society endangers our
future."
The book grew out of an article that I wrote
in Vanity Fair.
Vanity Fair is maybe not the usual media for
academics to publish in.
But the Vanity Fair article did get more attention
than my 1969 Econometrica article on the same
subject.
[laughter]
The title of the Vanity Fair article went
viral.
Was "Of the One Percent, By the One Percent,
For the One Percent."
And you can sort of get the tone of the article.
And it got picked up by a part of the chant
of the Occupy Wall Street.
The issues that I'm talking about are not
the politics of envy as one of the political
candidates has said.
One of the political candidates has said "You
shouldn't be talking about inequality except
to quiet rooms in hushed tones."
But in fact, I believe that inequality is
one of the most important problems our society
faces today.
And needs to be talked about actually quite
loudly.
What most Americans do not realize is that
quietly without people noticing it, America
has become the advanced industrial country
with the highest level of inequality.
And we were already at, had that distinction
a number of years ago.
But while other countries have worked hard
to contain the inequality, to slow the increase.
In recent years the level of inequality in
the United States has been increasing markedly.
Just a couple examples, the share of income
that accrues to the upper one percent has
doubled from 10 percent in 1980 to 20 percent
today.
The, there are a number of other statistics
that describe the degree of inequality.
Perhaps one, two, I think that maybe I should
mention in the beginning here.
One of them is that Americans like to think
of our country as a land of opportunity.
It really defines part of the American identity.
But in fact, that notion that America is a
land of opportunity is really a myth.
Now we all know people who've made it from
the bottom to the top, middle to the top.
Immigrants who come to the United States and
succeeded.
But from the point of view of the economist,
what's relevant is the statistics.
Not the examples, not the exceptions, but
what happens on average.
And on average, America is less equal even
than old Europe, let alone any of the other
advanced industrial counties for which there's
data.
What does that mean?
It means that the life prospects of a young
kid in the United States is more dependent
on the education and income of his parents
than in any other country.
And you can see, it gets reflected in a number
of aspects.
Both in terms of movement, up, but also movement
down.
People at the top who don't do very, whose
children don't do very well in school, wind
up with higher income than people from the
bottom and middle whose children do very well
in school.
So it really shows the influence of parents
in determining opportunity in the United States.
Some of you may have seen the article that
appeared yesterday reflecting the outcome
results of the Fed's survey of wealth and
income in the United States.
The most recent one.
And it was very, very telling.
You know, it would be one thing if all that
success at the top benefited everybody.
And the idea that that was so is called 'trickle
down' economics.
You know, you throw enough money at the top,
and everybody benefits.
The evidence is to the contrary.
That while the top has done very well, the
median, people 50 percent below, 50 percent
above.
Median income in the United States today is
lower than it was a decade and a half ago.
And what's been happening to wealth is even
more troubling.
The top one percent controls about 40 percent
of all the wealth.
But the recession was really, really bad for
most Americans in terms, not only in terms
of income, but even more so in terms of wealth.
Not a surprise.
But with people at the bottom and middle putting
all their wealth into the homes, when the
home prices went down, on average over 30
percent, in some areas over 50 percent, they
lost a very large fraction of their wealth.
So in fact, the wealth, particularly of the
middle, and the bottom, is now back to where
it was over two decades ago.
No increase in wealth over two decades.
The, in the recovery from the crisis in 2010,
we got another picture of the degree of inequality
in our society.
93 percent of the growth that occurred in
2010 went to the upper one percent.
So again, most Americans are not sharing in
what's going on.
It would be one thing, as I said, if the success
of those at the top income benefited everybody.
But it hasn't.
And also it would be one thing if the successes
at the top reflected their contribution to
society.
This is not about envy.
The question is, have they really made contributions
that are commensurate with their incomes?
And those of you who study elementary economics
know this is a 19th century theory called
the 'marginal productivity theory.'
Well, the crisis actually gave lie to that
theory.
We all saw in the crisis the bankers walking
off with huge bonuses even though they brought
to the global economy to the brink of ruin.
Even though they brought their own company
to the brink of ruin.
In fact, some of the banks were so embarrassed
about calling these bonuses "performance bonuses"
that they changed the name to "retention bonuses".
There was no "performance" so they had to
have another name.
But then the question was "Why would you wanna
retain somebody who had messed up your company
so badly?" and all this actually speaks to
one of the key issues that I raise in the
book.
What is the true source of wealth?
Of those say, at the top?
If you look at the list of people at the top,
it doesn't include the great innovators.
You know the people who invented the computer,
Turing.
It doesn't include the people who invented
the transistor.
The laser.
That discovered DNA.
None of these people who really made important
contributions to our society are in that list
of the wealthiest in our society.
It's basically with the argument I have is,
a very large proportion of these are people
that economists call "rent seekers."
Let me try to explain what the concept of
rent-seeking is.
You can see it in a couple ways.
There are two ways to create wealth.
To get wealth.
One of them is to make the size of the national
pie larger.
And to get a share of that increase.
The other one is to try to seize a larger
share of the existing pie.
And that's what rent seekers do.
And in that process they actually make the
pie smaller.
So an example are monopolists.
How do monopolists make their profits?
Partly by restricting output.
They're making the output actually smaller
than it otherwise would be.
And yet that can generate large, large incomes
for themselves.
So if you look at the disproportionate people
at the top, they are in this group of what
economists will call rent seekers.
Let me give you a couple other examples.
When the bankers engage in predatory lending,
or abusive credit card practices, what they're
doing is moving money.
They're not creating value.
What they're doing is taking money from poor
Americans, financially unsophisticated Americans
and moving it from the bottom to the top.
That doesn't create wealth.
It actually in some sense destroys wealth.
Why does it destroy wealth?
Well, one of the most important resources
of any society are their human talent.
The young people.
And when you devote those people to this task
of moving money from the poor people.
Through predatory lending.
You misallocating your scarcest human resource.
So it's not a surprise, and this is really
one of the most important points of the book.
It's not a surprise that economies in which
the divide is larger, when the inequality
is larger, grow more slowly.
You see that in the history of the United
States and the period in the decades after
World War II.
We had just fought a war together.
And there was a sense of national cohesiveness.
We passed laws like the GI Bill, that provided
education for all.
The result of that was our economy went through
the most rapid period of economic growth and
it was a period in which every part of our
economy grew.
Those at the bottom grew most rapidly.
So that the divide between the top and the
bottom got reduced.
Since 1980 what has happened is growth has
slowed.
And the divide has grown.
And that's not an accident.
And one of the things I try to do in the book
is to try to explain why there is this negative
correlation between inequality and growth.
Why inequality is bad for economic growth.
And there are a couple factors that help explain
it.
One of them is, this phenomena of rent-seeking
that I just described.
That resources got misallocated to seeking
rents, rather than to producing increasing
value.
And there are a whole list of the kinds of
rent-seeking activities.
When the drug companies spend money to persuade
congress to give them a drug, to pass a law
that says "The us government, while it's the
largest purchaser of drugs, cannot bargain
with the drug companies, the result of which
gives the drug companies a gift over 10 years
of a half a trillion dollars.
Money that could go into making our economy
more productive.
That's rent-seeking activity that does not
lead to a stronger economy.
When we have a tax law again, as a result
of lobbying, that says that speculators should
be taxed at less than half a rate, the rate
that those who work for a living.
Because the special provisions capital gains,
we're destroying our economy.
More resources move into speculation.
Less into creative activity.
And again, our economy is weaker.
It's also of course, not fair.
And it's one of the reasons that the top one
percent pays an average tax rate of 15 percent.
Which is much less than those whose income
is substantially lower.
There are other reasons that inequality is
bad for our economy.
For an economy to work well, there needs to
be a basic level of public spending on basic,
on what you might call the common good.
You have to have investments in education,
public education.
One of the reasons why we've become a less
equal society is that we are not investing
as much in public education.
People in California know that access to the
university is becoming much less restricted.
And it's not as open as it was 30 years ago.
And these are things that mean that many young
people are not gonna live up to their potential.
And again a waste of resources.
You need to invest in technology.
Google.
A lot of the most important innovations of
the recent decades are based on government
funded research.
The internet was supported by government funded
research.
We've been living off, draining the well,
of ideas that basic research helped support.
But we haven't been refilling the well.
And that requires government support.
National Science Foundation.
NIH.
All kinds of things.
We've underfunded those.
And finally you need infrastructure.
Any of you who've come into Kennedy Airport
know that America has been under investing
in our infrastructure.
A comparison between US airports and those
in Asia is embarrassing.
But you need ports and roads if you're gonna
export.
If you're gonna grow.
So.
We've not been investing in these things.
And one of the reasons we haven't, is when
you have a divided society, those at the top
worry that if you have too strong of a government,
it might use its powers to redistribute.
So they'd rather have a weak government that
can't do anything.
That's tied up.
That's gridlocked.
Than a government that might engage in redistribution.
I'll come back to that in the end.
But the point of all these are just, some
of the mechanisms by which inequality leads
to poorer economic performance.
There's one more final one I want to mention
that's gotten a lot of attention more recently.
It's not a surprise that the last time inequality
reached the kind of level that it's reached
more recently in the United States was during
the "roaring '20s."
Right before the Great Depression.
And the IMF, the UN Commission, that investigated
the global financial crisis.
Other scholars have come to the consensus
that inequality is systematically associated
with instability.
We have time later in the question period.
I can try to go through the mechanism by which
that happens.
But it is a regularity.
And so one way of thinking about it is, when
you move money, people at the top save a larger
fraction of their income than people at the
bottom.
So you move money from the bottom to the top,
there's a lack of demand.
Or there would be a lack of demand unless
something is done about it.
And what the Fed did about it was to create
a bubble.
[chuckles] And it worked.
For a while.
But it put our economy in jeopardy.
And this has happened not only this time,
but it's happened on other occasions.
So all of these are reasons why greater inequality
is associated with weaker economic performance.
And that's really one of the main themes of
the book, of "The Price of Inequality."
We're paying a high price for this inequality.
This is a markedly different perspective than
that taken by those on the right.
Those on the right say "We understand you
don't like inequality.
We wish we could get rid of inequality.
But we can't without paying a very high price."
Now old textbooks used to talk about a tradeoff.
You can get lower inequality but at the cost
of, lower growth, less economic efficiency.
There's a tradeoff.
So that what they said in fact was that the
price that you, not only the top would pay,
but everybody would have to pay if we try
to reduce the degree of inequality is just
too high.
What my book argues is quite the contrary.
That in fact, we are paying a price for not
attacking inequality.
That we could have, as I say, a stronger economy
and a more equal society.
One of the concerns I have is that this inequality
then starts to affect not only our economy
but our democracy, our system of justice.
Budget battles.
The conduct of macroeconomic policy.
I'll try to explain it in a few minutes how
inequality has this kind of pervasive affect
on our society.
Before that I wanna discuss a puzzle that
arises in political science.
In political theory.
We're supposed to have a democracy.
And in a democracy with one person, one vote,
the outcome of the democracy is supposed to
reflect the middle.
There's a well-developed theory that some
of you may have studied, called "the medium
voter."
That the medium voter, half want more spending,
half want less spending.
And you can go through any issue in the medium
voter theory describes, it's the person in
the middle that's supposed to be determining
where our polity goes.
But if you look at the United States, you
look at the decisions we've made in our politics,
it's very clear that that doesn't describe
what's going on.
If you look at what's going on, it's better
described by a theory of one dollar, one vote,
than one person, one vote.
And the question is, why?
'cause we have a democracy.
Why is the outcome so different?
Well, in discussing the economics and how
the economy leads to the degree of inequality
that we have, what I point out is that it's
not just market forces.
Market forces are universal.
They affect countries all over the world.
But the way we shape marked forces has resulted
in the US having more inequality than any
other country.
So laws and regulation help to shape market
forces.
An example, for instance, is take a bankruptcy
law.
Every country has a bankruptcy law but we
are distinct.
We have two provisions in our bankruptcy law
that is distinctive.
Are distinctive.
One of them is at the top, we give priority
to derivatives.
That says that if a company goes bankrupt,
the derivatives, the CDSs are paid off before
anybody else, before workers, before anybody
else.
And we have a law like that, that encourages
derivatives.
These speculative products.
Remember that AIG had a 150 billion dollar
bailout?
That was a result of government encouraging
this through our bankruptcy law.
At the other end, this may be a sensitive
subject, but in the United States we have
another distinctive provision of our bankruptcy
law that students cannot discharge their loans
even in bankruptcy.
Even if the school does not provide the education
that they promised.
You know, in other areas of our life, companies
say, "Satisfaction guaranteed or your money
back."
These for-profit schools say, "Satisfaction
is almost guaranteed not to occur."
Because they all, dropout rates are huge.
But you never get your money back, and in
fact, we're gonna be on your shoulders for
the rest of your life."
Well that's the result of politics.
Of the laws that we passed that shape our
economy.
That encourage people to provide education
that doesn't really serve the needs.
Because they can get their money back.
Well, the same thing is true about politics.
That the way our political system works is
shaped by the rules and regulations.
If you have rules and regulations that say,
for instance, affecting lobbying, campaign
contributions, revolving doors, they determine
the influence of the one percent.
The people at the top.
So like, the citizens united, the supreme
court decisions that will allow corporations
to give unbridled spending gave more influence
to those at the top.
The consequence of this is that we have a
vicious circle.
Where economic inequality feeds into inequality
of political power.
And that inequality of political power leads
to rules and regulations that lead to more
economic inequality.
In a what I would call a downward vicious
circle.
In some ways it's even worse than I've just
described because as ordinary citizens see
this process in work, they become disillusioned.
They say "What good is it to vote?"
And you see the consequence of that in the
last election, 2010.
Where 80 percent of the young people said
it wasn't worth their while to exercise their
democratic right to vote.
That's astounding.
Other countries are marching to get the right
to vote.
Countries fighting to get democracy.
We have democracy but 80 percent of the young
people said it wasn't worth the trouble of
going to the poll.
Because no matter who wins, wall street wins.
The one percent wins.
And it's not gonna affect what happened.
But then that itself gives more power to money.
Because money then has to be used to get out
the vote.
And they targeted getting out the vote to
those who will support their views.
So that's one of the reasons why we've wound
up with this kind of distorted democracy that
we have.
The other reason that I talk about briefly
is based on some insights from recent research
and behavioral economics.
College-age marketing.
Corporations have discovered that they can
market goods.
Good example is for instance, the cigarette
companies.
Were able to persuade most Americans that
there was no credible evidence that cigarettes
caused cancer.
Or had other ill-health effects.
Even though the cigarette companies had in
their files that evidence.
But they were very effective in casting doubt
about the nature of the scientific evidence.
And people continued to smoke for several
decades after the evidence was overwhelming.
Well, if you can sell toxic products you can
also sell toxic ideas.
And the one percent has both the resources,
the tools, the techniques and the incentive
to do that.
And that's again, played a very important
role in shaping our politics.
And helps explain why we wound up with these
outcomes that seem so out of line with what
you would expect to get in a democratic society.
Let me talk just very briefly about three
other, two or three other manifestations of
this inequality.
Not only has it put our democracy at peril.
It's also put our system of justice at peril.
One of the basic values I think that most
Americans take seriously is justice for all.
You know, in the Pledge of Allegiance, we
say "Justice for all."
But in the recent mortgage crisis the mortgage
debacle, what we saw was not justice for all.
Many Americans were thrown out of their homes
when they didn't owe anything.
The banks signed an affidavit, said that they'd
looked at the record, and said that this individual
owed money.
But they were lying.
They hadn't looked at the record.
This was the robo-signing where they just
had so many signed thousands of these a day.
They hadn't looked at the record.
And obviously if you haven't looked at the
record you're gonna make a lot of mistakes.
Now the banks response is that most of the
people that they threw out of their homes
did owe money.
That's like a system of justice that says
"most of the people that get capital punishment
were probably guilty.
They must have done something wrong."
But that's not our system of justice.
"Innocent until proven guilty."
The burden of proof.
But the fact of the matter is, after all of
this has been brought to light, not one of
the people who committed this kind of perjury
to the court, over and over again.
Not just once, over and over again, has gone
to prison.
There is some attempt to get financial reparations
to make up for the people who have been thrown
out of their homes.
But the result of this if you look and this
is just one example, we've wound up with a
system that is better described, not "justice
for all" but "justice for those who can afford
it."
Now take another issue that's been very big
in the United States in recent years.
The battle over the budget.
How do we bring down the deficit?
And if I begin to analyze that problem, I
begin with a very simple observation.
Just a little over 10 years ago, 2001, the
US had a large surplus.
So large that Alan Greenspan said that he
was worried.
He was worried we were gonna pay back the
entire national debt and that would be very
hard for him to conduct monetary policy with
no national debt.
You know the details of how monetary policy
is conducted, is buying and selling national
debt.
Now you should understand that this was a
totally specious argument.
And incredible that anybody took Alan Greenspan
seriously.
But then he was a hero.
I cannot believe that if say, in 2015, those
surpluses had persisted and we almost paid
down the national debt, Alan Greenspan or
a successor could have come to Congress and
the Administration and say "You know our country
faces a real emergency.
You need to spend more to create a debt.
And I know you don't wanna spend.
But sacrifice, but your country in front of
anybody else.
Cut taxes, spend more.
Please, please."
I can't believe that congress would not have
responded and relatively quickly to this national
emergency.
[laughter]
But somehow Alan Greenspan said "No, we can't
wait until that dire moment, we have to act
in 2001 to give a tax cut to the richest Americans.
Let's not look at the details of whether we
can afford it.
Let's get that tax cut right on the books
as soon as we can."
What that shows you was that macro-economic
policy, monetary economic policy, these independent
central bankers really often have a political
agenda.
They're not these god-like figures who are
only worrying about the details of inflation
and so forth.
But more to the point, if you understand that
just over a decade ago we had a surplus and
you see the large deficits, where would a
reasonable place of beginning to get rid of
the deficits?
Well, to ask, how did we go from that surplus
to the deficit and let's see if we should
reverse those?
And there are actually only four things.
This tax cut that we couldn't afford, especially
for the top.
Two very expensive wars that didn't do anything
and a military buildup beyond that.
Weapons that don't work against enemies that
don't exist.
That's the good news.
That the enemies aren't there.
The Cold War is over.
The Defense Department doesn't seem to know
it yet.
Thirdly, a drug benefit for, I mentioned before
that we don't bargain with the drug companies.
And that's a half a trillion dollar giveaway
over 10 years.
And finally, probably one of the most important
is, the recession.
And this is very important.
The deficit didn't cause the recession.
The recession caused the deficit.
The best way of getting the deficit down would
be put America back to work.
To create jobs.
To get America functioning again.
Well, if you look at the deficit reduction
commissions, a whole set of them.
What you see is they don't focus on the issues
that I've just described.
There are all kinds of things.
Like, can you imagine a deficit reduction
commission that says "Let's lower the corporate
income tax."
Now how does that help reduce the deficit?
Now I agree, you need to reform the tax structure
to get rid of all the loopholes.
That's important.
But, lowering the rate?
What you should be doing is saying "Let's
lower the rate on firms that invest in America
and raise the rate on firms that don't invest
in America."
That would provide the incentive for the creation
of more jobs.
Well, I want to conclude by saying, by discussing
what is it that we can do about this problem?
In the last chapter I provide an economic
agenda.
There are many aspects of America's inequality.
Too much wealth at the top.
Too many poor people.
People in poverty have increased.
A hollowing out of the middle class.
And each of these requires its own agenda.
There's no magic bullet.
There's gonna be lots of things.
Every law and regulation like the bankruptcy
law, competition law, corporate governance
laws that allow CEOs to take a larger share
of the pie, of the corporations.
All of these things help shape the inequality
that we have in our society today.
And so you can't just do one thing.
There are many things.
But it's all doable.
It's actually not that complicated.
And other countries have done one or more
of the things that I describe in that agenda.
The problem of course, is the politics.
And our political system is distorted so the
question, and it works for the one percent,
the question is how are we gonna reform the
politics?
So I end, the question, is there hope?
And my publisher told me that people don't
buy books if there's no hope.
[laughter]
They don't want to finish a book and be depressed.
It's just not, at least part of the American
personality.
A few years ago I think I came here and gave
a talk about my book with Linda Bilmes called
"The Three-Trillion-Dollar War."
And the book was very influential in shaping
the debate about the war.
When people started using the, the war, they
said "the three-trillion-dollar war."
And it helped people understand the huge cost
of the war.
We were very explicit.
We had underestimated the cost of the war.
In particular the numbers that have come in
since then have shown that we were accurate.
And we were right that we had underestimated
close to one out of two Americans coming back
from Afghanistan and Iraq are disabled.
And that's going to cost us a trillion dollars
in the coming years to pay for their health
and disability payments.
But anyway, the point is, not that many people
bought that book.
'cause it was so depressing.
[laughter]
So let me end on a note of hope.
The United States has had, well, we'll get
two notes of hope.
If you look around the world, there are some
other countries that have looked over the
precipice and said, "We don't wanna go there.
One in particular, Brazil, had very high levels
of inequalities.
And then beginning with President Cardoso,
just about 20 years ago he said "This is not
the direction that we wanna go."
And there was a broad consensus in the society.
Including the one percent.
They understood it was in their enlightened
self interest to do something about this.
Otherwise their whole society was gonna fall
apart.
And the result of that was a successful program
of bringing up education.
And then President Lula had a program to make
sure there was , that the problems of hunger
or the problems of access to health care for
poor children was addressed.
And remarkably, in 20 years, you can see that
Brazil is bringing down the level of inequality.
It's been working.
So and today you go visit Brazil, and there
already is across the spectrum, from business
people to unions, a consensus about the direction
their economy, their society, should be going.
In the United States, we've reached high levels
of inequality a couple of other times.
The Gilded Age.
The Roaring '20s.
Each time we looked over the precipice and
we said "That's not the direction we wanna
go."
The Gilded Age was followed by the Progressive
era.
Legislation like anti-trust legislation.
The Roaring '20s was followed by a whole set
of legislation.
The Wagner act.
Social security.
Laws about hours and working conditions.
That really served to re-balance our society.
Reduce the level of inequality.
And the question today is, will Americans
wake up to the degree of inequality and the
lack of equality of opportunity that we have
today?
And will they pull back from the brink?
And the hope of this book is that they will.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Male #1: Let's talk about your vanity fair
article, 'cause that actually made sense to
me.
So your story is that it's in the interest
of the one percent to preserve a stable economy.
So I wanna question some of the statements
you made in this talk.
I looked at the numbers for when inequality
went down and one time was between '29 and
'33.
Because the stock market collapsed.
And the real estate market collapsed.
And we poor homeless folk, we don't own any
real estate, so it didn't hurt us any.
And another time it, the inequality level
decreased was between fall 2008 and spring
2009.
And that was the same situation.
Poor people didn't have any money in the first
place.
Rich people lost all their money they had
in stocks and real estate.
So what makes the equality gap go down, is
actually having an economic collapse.
If I was in the one percent, I don't happen
to be, but if I was, I would really wanna
avoid that.
I would thank people like Roosevelt who restored
capitalism.
And Obama who restored capitalism again.
So how do we help the one percent avoid losing
all their money?
>>Joseph: Well, let me just make an important
reflection on the observation you made.
Which is, because there are all these fluctuations
because of cyclical disturbances that's why
we need to look at inequality over longer
periods of time.
But 10, 20 years is a longer period of time.
And therefore the recent data that I began
my talk with where 20 years of wealth accumulation
had been wiped out.
That's significant.
It's not just three years.
It's 20 years of wealth accumulation.
When I said that the median income adjusted
for inflation is lower than it was 15 years
ago, that's a long period of time.
If you ask the question, what's happened to
the median income of a full-time male worker?
It's lower today than it was in 1968, almost,
more than four decades ago.
These are not just cyclical fluctuations.
And really speak to the--
>>Male #1: Sorry, but that's not true either.
You're just looking at the United States.
If you look at the world wide.
People in China are just a lot better off
than they are now.
>>Joseph: Oh, I was talking about inequality
in the United States.
There are other countries.
I mentioned Brazil where things are getting
better.
Poverty is, the interesting thing in China
is that poverty has gone down remarkably but
inequality is going up.
And that shows you that there are many dimensions
to the distribution of income.
But I should get the next person.
Yeah.
>>Male #2: thanks for your book.
And for your talk.
I have a question about the marketing and
propaganda basically, and I mean that in a
positive way, about ideas.
It seems that republicans do a much much better
job pedaling their version of the world to
all of us than people who are democrats.
And I'll cite two examples.
One of them is this phrase "death tax" that
was created by Frank Lunz and all of his focus
group testing.
The Cope brothers, etcetera, etcetera.
They wanted to eliminate the estate tax.
Well that would cause other taxes to go up
and other bad effects.
So they had to find a way to market that to
the 99 point nine percent people who aren't
really affected by the inheritance tax.
Or arent affected very much, I should say.
So they came up with this idea of "death tax"
and they made a big joke about it.
"Even when we are dying, there are taxes."
Another one, you were one KQED forum and you
had a gentleman yesterday who called in and
he talked about how half of Americans don't
pay any taxes.
Which is this meme that's been repeated and
repeated and repeated on talk radio and on
TV.
So these are two examples where Republicans
have found a way to reduce the complexity
of economics and all of this in a way that
really makes an impact on politics.
And I wonder if there's some organizations
that are doing it in a way that's consistent
with what you write in your book.
And, which is consistent with my economic
values.
I agree, the way that we're headed is not
good.
Even for people at the top one percent.
We're all gonna suffer from this.
We're suffering now.
So do you agree with my idea that we're kind
of losing, we're winning the economics battle,
we've got the economics right, but we're losing
the propaganda battle.
>>Joseph: Yeah.
>>Male #2: And what can we do about it?
And if I had some money to donate to it, where
should I donate?
>>Joseph: Well, I agree that this is in some
ways the key issue.
I suppose, I mean, and it's one of the reasons
I wrote the book because I wanted to try to
crystallize some of the arguments that are
wrong in the you might say, the conservative
interpretation of inequality.
So I suppose if you're willing to do something,
I would say buy a lot of copies of my book
and give them to all your
[laughter]
Friends and neighbors.
But [chuckles] more seriously, there are,
there is one Washington think tank that is
very concerned about this issue.
It's the Center for American Progress.
To how do we get across this particular message.
Set of messages.
And in the book, I look at this example of
the "death duty".
And it's astounding.
You know, most Americans opposed the repeal,
opposed the death duty.
Even though in the United States, if a married
couple will only pay the death duty if their
income, their wealth, their bequests, exceeds
10 million dollars.
Now, there aren't many Americans, certainly
not the average American, is facing this dilemma
of what to do with their 10 million dollars.
I wish it were so.
But they simply don't know.
Moreover, they've been so, a lot of these
are several myths together.
They believe, "Oh yes, I don't have 10 million
dollars now, but we are a land of opportunity
and I'll become one of these guys with 10
million dollars."
Anything is possible, but the probability
is point zero, zero, zero, zero, zero, zero,
one.
So it could happen.
But it's not likely to happen.
So the question is, how do we give more fact
based discussion.
You talk about the bottom 10 percent, 15 percent
not paying taxes.
That ignores the fact that they pay sales
taxes, property taxes, a whole set of other
kinds of taxes.
>>Male #2: [inaudible] taxes.
>>Joseph: So it is really distortion of the
stories.
So what I've tried to do in the book is tried
to explain at least some of those distortions
and what the truth about those matters are.
>>Male #2: I think that's good, but I still
think we need like two bumper sticker phrases.
>>Joseph: I agree.
But I'm not good at bumper sticker phrases.
>>Male #2: Because the book
>>Joseph: As you've just seen from my long
talk, I'm much better at long winded answers
than bumper stickers.
>>Male #2: So the Center for American Progress
is a good place to go?
>>Joseph: Right.
They're trying very hard.
They've come up with a little pamphlet actually.
The American Middle Class, Income Inequality,
and the Strength of our Economy.
Where they've tried to articulate this in
simple terms.
But it's where they're trying to go.
And they're trying to get, I and people like
them are trying to get President Obama who
does hopefully have a knack for articulating
these things in a way that will have resonance.
>>Male #2: thank you very much.
>>Male #3: So you mentioned wanting to leave
people with hope.
Well I'm from Wisconsin and was recently involved
in the Recall Movement.
So I'm desperately in need of some hope.
[laughter]
So for those who don't know in Wisconsin we
had a fairly radical anti-union governor who
played with various budget manipulations and
then kinda drove the state into a ditch and
then blamed it on public employees.
And in this recent recall election, the incumbent
Scott Walker's side had seven times the spending
on campaign materials and on advertising that
his challenger Tom Barrett did.
And the majority of that came from very wealthy
out of state donors, many of whom were able
to remain anonymous because they didn't give
directly to his campaign but because they
gave to superpacs.
Which are allowed by the recent Citizens United
decision.
And this kinda ties in with what the previous
person was talking about.
But how do we change the political system
to promote better outcomes in the economy
and less inequality, if there is already such
a tremendous inequality in the money that
goes into the political system?
And you have a situation, I mean, is our only
hope to rely on relatively enlightened one
percenters?
Like say Warren Buffet?
Who have a distaste for superpac spending?
As well they should.
I mean, what is the path out of that?
>>Joseph: I think there are two that I sorta
outline in my book.
One of them is that eventually enough of the
one percent realize this is not in their interests.
And there are people like Warren Buffet who've
been very articulate about the dangers of
going the direction that we're going.
Not only dangers but the fundamental inequity
that he pays a lower tax rate than his secretary.
The other one is reflects my other perspective.
That I, that the 99 percent might finally
begin to realize that they've been sold a
bill of goods.
That what is in the one percent interests
may not be in their best interests.
Some of it is, but some of it is not.
Low tax rates for speculators is not in their
interest.
There's a whole set of, a system of appropriately
designed estate taxes really does help, raise
needed revenue, enhances equality of opportunity.
So there are a whole set of reforms that it
should be possible to articulate that the
99 percent will realize is in their interests.
And that there is this potential conflict
and that will change our democratic process.
We're still are a democracy, and we still
have the potential of changing the legislation.
>>Male #4: so I'm sympathetic to the argument
that wealth inequalities can be economic inefficient.
But isn't it dangerous to talk about "the
one percent" because it sort of conflates
income and wealth.
Which are very different things?
And also, it sort of presents "the one percent"
as a homogeneous group.
Whereas people at the bottom end of that,
who aren't poor by any means, they still aren't
going to buy any influence in Washington.
Whereas the upper percentiles of the one percent
are qualitatively different.
So why do you use the term "one percent" and
what
>>Joseph: I use it because you have to simplify.
And in the book, I raise exactly the point,
when I use the words "one percent" I'm using
generically for something above the top.
And some of those at the, and I do make the
point that the one percent in wealth is not
the same as the one percent in income.
And that
>>Male #4: But still they're kind of fundamentally
different remedies.
Like the only way you're ever going to penalize
the Walton heirs is through an estate tax.
There's no income tax that will ever change
that inequality.
>>Joseph: Let me just, one of the numbers
that I mention in the book that it's gotten
a lot of resonance is the fact that the six
heirs to the Walton fortune have as much money,
much wealth, as the bottom 30 percent of America.
And that is a testimony both to the wealth
at the top and to the lack of wealth at the
bottom.
But you're absolutely right.
That's something that's going to need the
estate tax.
And what I said was, that we have many dimensions
of inequality in our society.
And each of them requires their own remedy.
We also have inequality in health outcomes.
And that, the remedy of that is, a better
healthcare system.
So there are many of these dimensions and
obviously in a short talk I couldn't go into
all of them.
Also, you're all, absolutely right that it's
unfair to the one percent to lump them all
together.
I mentioned that Warren Buffet has actually
been very articulate in saying that we oughta
do, a system of taxation is unfair.
He even addressed the issue of class warfare
when he said, you know, cause one of the reactions
to some of the statements that I've made and
others like it is "You're fomenting class
warfare."
And his response was, and this is from somebody
at the very top, he said "We've been at class
warfare for a very long time, and our class
has been winning."
So he gave I think a perspective on what is
at stake.
This is not about class warfare.
This is about how you make our society work
better.
>>Male #4: Thank you.
>>Female #1: Hi, I'm just going a little bit
off topic here.
But I'm wondering as an economist who's focused
on inequality from an economic standpoint,
how do you feel about Obama's nomination for
World Bank President?
>>Joseph: Well, this, it's an interesting
nomination.
I don't know if you know, the first point
I'll make is that the G20, had agreed that
the next president of the World Bank ought
to be chosen on the basis of merit.
That traditionally it's always based on, it's
always been an American.
And they said "Why does America have the monopoly
on talented people?
There's actually a world out there.
And we oughta open it up."
And the US agreed to that, sort of.
But and everybody had expected this case would
be one where countries would put forward good
candidates and there'd be an open and fair
competition.
Well it turned out that it was more open than
there had previously been.
There were two very good candidates from developing
countries.
So, Antonio Compo from Columbia, and Ngoze
from Nigeria.
Both really outstanding people who would have
made good presidents of the World Bank.
Both with a lot of experience.
Both who had served as senior ministers in
their government.
Head of Foreign Policy.
Head of Economics.
You know, so a lot of experience.
In the end, the United States, said, "Oh,
we didn't really mean chosen on the basis
of merit.
We meant a good American.
As opposed to somebody like Wolfowitz who
was not a good American."
[laughter]
So the good news of the G20 was the Administration
had been considering appointing somebody who
would have been a disaster.
And the fact that there was a more open process
meant that everybody could pile in and tell
Obama "Don't do that.
That would be a mistake."
And there was a lot of press discussion.
And he decided not to appoint that person.
Last minute he got the guy that, Tim, that
he chose.
A person who's done fantastic work in the
area of health.
At least a lot of people say.
You don't, but, but that's only one part of
the portfolio of the World Bank.
And so the concern is that it's, it's not
sufficiently broad relative to the needs of
what the World Bank.
But we'll see how that evolves.
>>Female #2: Hi, so I've done some reading
and research on the relationship, if any,
between a country's ethnic fractualization
or the ethnic or racial relations of a country
and its economic growth especially with variables
like corruption or like rent-seeking like
you talked about earlier.
So I'm just wondering what your perspective
is on that type of research.
Ike what your perspective is on the theory
and how you think it's maybe relevant to the
US and inequality.
>>Joseph: Yeah, that's actually interesting.
There is this body of research that basically
is focused on different, how societies work
together and the extent to which there can
be ethnic divisions.
A lot in Africa where you have tribal divisions.
Some interesting aspects of it is, when you
have two or three groups, things work worse
than if there's either one group, or very
many groups.
I think that it's relevant in the following
sense.
That it is clear that some more homogeneous
societies like the Scandinavian countries
have managed to have a higher degree of cohesiveness.
Have much broader policies that support greater
equality.
And have grown together.
But I think at the same time while America
is a very diverse society, there's absolutely
nothing about any of the policies that I've
described here that couldn't be implemented
in a very diverse society.
>>Female #2: Thank you.
>>Male #5: Hi.
You made a point about how rent-seeking can
shrink the economic pie.
I'm wondering if you have any thoughts about
whether labor unions exhibit rent-seeking
behavior and how that affects the economy.
>>Joseph: That's a good question.
Labor unions have played both an important
and in some cases an ambiguous role.
[pause] The reason that unions originally
grew to the importance that they have is that
there was an imbalance in economic power.
Particularly bargaining power.
One, when the introduction was talked about
game theory.
The standard economic models pretend that
there is perfect competition.
And there's a, just a supply of labor and
a demand for labor and everything works out
very smoothly.
The reality is not, that doesn't describe
the reality.
There is a difference in bargaining power.
And again, one of the points I make in the
book is that the rules and regulations of
how we run our economy affect that bargaining
power.
For instance, when we run globalization in
a way that we say that capital and goods can
move anywhere in the world, but labor can't,
that affects bargaining power.
Because a firm bargaining with workers can
say to the workers "If you dont take lower
wages, we're gonna move somewhere else and
then we're gonna be able to bring the goods
back home."
So it totally distorts the bargaining power.
I tell my students "Think of another world
with a different set of rules.
Let's assume that we have a set of rules that
capital couldn't move, but skilled labor could.
So an economy would have to compete for skilled
labor.
And so they would compete by having old schools,
good environment.
Totally different world than the world that
we live in."
The important lesson of this is that rules
and regulations do affect the bargaining power.
In that kind of a world, unions have played
an important role in trying to redress the
imbalance that has emerged naturally and out
of the distortions in the rules and regulations.
Now there are some cases where they themselves
have high bargaining power and have tried
to use that for obviously the benefit of their
members and particularly sometimes their older
members.
And that's had an adverse affect.
The point of that is, you don't say, let's
get rid of all unions.
You have to understand the role that unions
play and try to correct the problems that
have arisen in those unions.
>>Female Presenter: Not a question.
But a thank you for coming to Google.
[applause]